legal eagle is coming in loud and clear
thanks to ting and mobile
today we're talking about
[Music]
where the wind doesn't come sweeping
down the plane and the wave in wheat
does not smell sweet because it appears
that oklahoma
is no more is it possible that the
supreme court gave away
half of the state well in what some
people are calling legal insanity the
supreme court in the mcgregor case has
decided that
native americans still have reservations
in most of
eastern oklahoma in an area that
includes tulsa
the supreme court says that native
american reservations have jurisdiction
over
some of the crimes that happen in that
huge swath of
eastern oklahoma and justice roberts is
warning that this is just the tip of the
iceberg that
perhaps all of the laws may eventually
fall under the reservation jurisdiction
and
no longer be part of oklahoma so the
question is
did the supreme court just give away
half of oklahoma
[Music]
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
a lawyer because if you live in tulsa
oklahoma
you might be wondering whose laws you
have to follow and
who you have to pay your taxes to but
some of the more fundamental questions
are what is a native american
reservation
and how does that impact the laws that
apply in a given geographical area
and does eastern oklahoma belong to the
state of oklahoma or
other native american reservations or
did oklahoma ever
in fact exist as a state itself
well the bombshell decision of mcgirt
versus oklahoma
delves into the interplay between state
law and the validity of land rights
established by treaties granted by the
u.s government
with some including the dissent
contending that this decision will upend
governance in oklahoma and i've had many
people ask what this case
is really about and you would think that
a decision that begins with the words
on the far end of the trail of tears was
a promise
will surely find its way into case law
books in the future but this was a 5-4
decision that's even more interesting
because the author of the majority
opinion
justice neil gorsuch broke with his
right-leaning cohorts on the supreme
court and of course it gets even more
interesting with multiple dissents with
clarence thomas
writing his own dissent because more
often than not thomas can't even agree
with the majority of the minority
in its entirety so without further ado
let's break down the incredible case of
mcgirt versus the state of oklahoma and
find out what's going on here
so this case starts with the conviction
of one named jim c mcgirt
which of course is the most oklahoma
name you've ever heard in your entire
life and mcgirt was found guilty of
three sexual offenses and sentenced to
life in prison in 1996.
he challenged his conviction on the
basis that the oklahoma state court
lacked jurisdiction to prosecute him
because
he's an enrolled member of the seminole
nation of oklahoma
and his crimes took place on designated
reservation land
and if indeed that's true that mcgirt's
crimes took place on
reservation lynn then he should have
been prosecuted in federal court not
oklahoma state court under the major
crimes act
the deciding factor for purposes of the
supreme court analysis was whether the
land given to native americans in
treaties by the u.s government
remains an indian reservation for
purposes of federal criminal law now
before we dive into the specific
arguments by both the petitioner and the
state of oklahoma i think it's important
to provide some
history here because that backdrop
informs this particular case
and explains why these treaties existed
in the first place most remember in
middle school history class learning
about what is commonly referred to as
the trail of tears
and here's a quick refresher in the
1830s native americans occupied large
tracts of land in states such as georgia
tennessee north carolina alabama and
florida they resided on this land for
generations of course long before
columbus the pilgrims or the mayflower
because of the viability of this land
white settlers wanted to use their land
for farming so in 1830
president andrew jackson signed the
indian removal act which
gave the federal government authority to
exchange
this land held by native americans for
land out west
in an indian colonization zone which is
now
present-day oklahoma faced with an
invasion by the u.s government and
all of the atrocities that we know go
hand in hand with that the native
americans left behind their homes which
were looted while they were forced to
journey on foot
to the land in oklahoma without any
supplies or assistance from the
government that was kicking them out
thousands of native americans lost their
lives on this forced expedition
which is why one tribal leader
accurately referred to it as a trail of
tears and death
four thousand people died on the trail
of tears
now while the main issues involved
whether there is a reservation or if it
was
disestablished by congress and what that
means it's important to know why
this determination has such a
significant impact in 1885
congress passed the major crimes act
which places certain crimes committed by
native americans
in native american territory as subject
to federal not state jurisdiction it
states that within
quote the indian country any indian who
commits certain enumerated offenses
against the person or property of
another indian
or any other person shall be subject to
the same law and penalties as
all other persons committing any of the
above offenses within the exclusive
jurisdiction of the united states
the mca defines quote indian country as
all land within the limits of any indian
reservation
under the jurisdiction of the united
states government not withstanding the
issuance of any patent and including
rights of way running through the
reservation
so the determination of reservation or
no reservation is the difference between
some crimes being adjudicated by the
federal court
as opposed to the state court so let's
turn to the issues that were
at issue in mcgirt versus oklahoma the
first question is did
congress establish a native american
reservation in the first place if there
was no reservation established then the
petitioner's entire argument would be
moot
state law not the federal mca would be
the controlling law
the majority opinion concluded that
mcgirt was right that congress did
establish a reservation
for the land in question large swaths of
oklahoma to arrive at this conclusion
the court had to scrutinize the original
treaty
with the group known as the creek nation
that was ratified and enacted into law
in 1833 the treaty
in no uncertain terms declared the
parcel of land that they were giving in
what is now located within
oklahoma to be a quote permanent home to
the whole creek nation of indians
the treaty even spells out how they
would accomplish this the united states
it provides would quote grant a patent
and fee
simple to the creek nation of indians
for the assigned land
to continue so long as they shall exist
as a nation and continue to occupy the
country hereby assigned to them within
these lands the creeks were to be
secured in their unrestricted right of
self-governments with full jurisdiction
over
all enrolled tribe members and their
property this treaty
though many oklahomans aren't happy
about it is not
really ambiguous it clearly defines the
large swaths of area that fall
under this treaty and become a native
american reservation so the next
question is does the reservation
still exist today or has it been
disestablished by subsequent
congressional
acts and the majority opinion notes that
over the years congress has violated its
treaty obligations and this
initially undivided land is now
fractured into various portions held by
tribe members and unaffiliated members
alike
nevertheless the court opinion notes
rather strongly
that federal treaties and statutes are
the supreme law of the land and that
it's up to
congress and congress alone to decide if
it wants to breach those treaties the
point being that
only congress not the states and
certainly not the judicial branch can
explicitly disestablish the reservation
this reminder of the importance of
separation of powers among the three
branches of government has been fleshed
out in
countless opinions as well as saturday
morning episodes of schoolhouse rockets
see it's kind of like my service
but in writing the opinion for the
majority justice gorsuch
summed it up pretty well saying that
legislators might seek to pass
laws that tiptoe to the edge of
disestablishment and hope that judges
facing no possibility of electoral
consequences themselves will deliver the
final push but wishes don't make for
laws and saving the political branches
the embarrassment of disestablishing a
reservation is not one of our
constitutionally insigned prerogatives
recall that gorsuch is a texturalist he
looks to the text
of the various laws and while he might
not agree with what the law says
politically
if he thinks that the text militates a
certain outcome
that's the way that he is going to vote
on the supreme court
the bottom line is that this is on
congress and if they want to
disestablish the reservation
they need to do it explicitly without
getting the courts to do its dirty work
but that's not the end of the inquiry
because the question remains
did some sort of subsequent act of
congress actually
disestablish the reservation oklahoma
actually claimed that congress did
disestablish the land within the
reservation
starting around the 1880s as a result of
the congressionally authorized daws
commission the
tribes were pressured to abandon their
customary communal living
and issue out individual tracts of lands
to its members
both the general allotment act of 1887
and the creek act of 1901
encouraged creek members to divide up
their lands this eventually resulted in
some individual tribe members
selling their land to non-native
americans as well but according to the
majority
this was nothing like an actual act of
congress disestablishing the entire
reservation
prior supreme court cases already had
held that allotment is
completely consistent with the continued
reservation status
moreover as we talked about the language
of the treaty itself also made this
clear by defining
indian country as all land within the
limits of any indian reservation not
withstanding the issuance of any patent
including any rights of way running
through the reservation in other words
the treaty provides for the land to be
encumbered and divided in a way that
doesn't affect the overall reservation
itself
and to drive the point home the court
provides an analogy that shows the
fallacy of equating allotment
in other words dividing up the land to
this establishment and
getting rid of the reservation entirely
the federal government
has issued its own allotments in the
form of what are called patents that
transfer legal title
to homesteads in the west and no one is
going to argue that the united states
sovereignty over the land that they gave
these homestead patents to is in any way
diminished because
of these particular acts and the same
holds true for the land owned by the
creek nation
the plan might have been to go from
allotment to disestablishment of the
reservation
but congress never followed through
and so the reservation still exists and
although congress took
other actions that impacted the creek
nation's reservation status like
abolishing their tribal courts and
transferring all of their pending civil
and criminal cases to united states
courts
the supreme court has held that none of
these acts disestablished the
reservation itself even what's called
the five civilized tribes act of 1906
which
took away more of the native american
rights stopped short of actually
disestablishing the reservation the
creek nation still retained their tribal
government power to do
such things as collect taxes operate
schools and legislate through tribal
ordinances
however arguably the strongest evidence
that the court provided was that in 1936
congress authorized the creek nation
to adopt a constitution and by laws
which actually restored powers
that they had previously been deprived
of and to give you a little idea of what
the government now looks like it
contains three separate branches of
government much like
the u.s government generally a
democratically elected principal chief
its own police force hospitals and an
annual budget of 350 million
so in other words the creek nation still
exists and so
does the reservation in most of eastern
oklahoma
now that said oklahoma and the descent
trying to use circumstantial evidence
and the land's demographics as evidence
of disestablishment
in defending their position oklahoma
suggested a three-step process to
determine disestablishment where the
court
a reviews the laws passed by congress b
examines the contemporary events at the
time these laws were passed
and c evaluates subsequent events and
demographics in laying out this approach
oklahoma and the descent
point out that the state's ongoing
practice of prosecuting native americans
located
in quote indian country for over a
century as well as the massive
influx of white settlers into the creek
nation's lands over the years
and they also point to various
statements made during the allotment era
including those from the creek nation
that seem to indicate that most believe
the reservation was on its last leg
and in the process of being
disestablished but the majority's
response
to this argument is basically thanks for
the history lesson but
that's not this positive it it doesn't
matter well the court didn't deny that
the context can be useful
it's only useful if the court is
interpreting ambiguous statutory terms
which is a common canon of construction
when you're
dealing with language whether it's a
statute
or a contract if you have a contract
dispute and
two parties want different things and
you look to the contract
and it's absolutely crystal clear then
there's no reason to then
think about what the parties might have
said in negotiating the contract because
the contractual language in this case is
perfectly clear
but if the contract isn't clear then
you're going to have to look at what's
called parole evidence
evidence outside of the four corners of
the contract to determine what to do and
that's what the court is doing here and
as far as the court was concerned there
weren't any ambiguous terms here the
treaty might be old but the terms were
clear
and as the majority pointed out oklahoma
and the dissenting justices couldn't
identify any cases where these kind of
extratextual considerations led to the
disestablishment of a reservation so
that takes us to
oklahoma's final sort of last-ditch
argument which actually the dissenters
in this case seized upon
and it's what we attorneys call a policy
argument a policy argument is designed
to appeal to common sense by
highlighting the real world impact that
a legal ruling could actually have
these types of arguments rely more on
the factual implications
of a ruling rather than the actual
statutory language or
constitutional framework and in this
case the argument went something like
this
if the court decides that the
reservation exists today then one of two
things could potentially happen
one other similarly situated tribes with
pre-existing treaties
will claim that their reservations still
exist as well with all the rights and
privileges that go along with that
number two and more to the point this
decision would disrupt both
the numerous convictions that have
already been doled out as well as their
ability to prosecute future crimes on
native american reservation land
and in the past these kinds of policy
arguments have actually worked to shoot
down native american claims
on their own land but here the majority
wasn't having it first they point out
that the mca is limited it only applies
to certain types of crimes and
b it does not apply to cases involving
non-native american victims or
defendants and the court also shoots
down the claim that the sky is falling
by reminding us that the population of
the area
only consists of 10 to 15 of native
americans and many convictions would not
be challenged because of the limitations
on post-conviction review and a desire
to not roll the dice in federal court
after all
just because you're not supposed to be
tried in state court doesn't mean you
get away it just means you're tried in
federal court instead and above all
justice gorsuch rejected such histrionic
claims saying that we proceed well aware
of the potential for cost and conflict
around jurisdictional boundaries
especially ones that have gone
unappreciated for so long
but it's unclear why pessimism should
rule the day with the passage of time
oklahoma and its tribes have proven that
they can work successfully together as
partners
and one of the things that's really
interesting about this particular case
is you get a sampling of the kinds of
arguments that you see in a lot of
different supreme court cases
some argue from the original text some
argue from the context in which laws
are passed and some just flat out reject
all of that and just argue from the
policy arguments but
it's interesting to see what worked in
this particular case and what didn't but
finally we get to
why you probably came to this video in
the first place
what are the implications of this
potentially momentous case
well in general this is an important
decision because first of all
gorsuch's opinion was seen as an
acknowledgment that often
native americans have been promised many
things by congress and those promises
have generally not been held up and here
gorsuch and the majority are holding
congress's feet to the fire
and making them uh follow through with
what was
originally promised even if it was
promised over
a hundred years ago or rather over 200
years ago and although congress has
diminished and restricted
different tribes authority on their
reservations severely
the reservation still exists until
congress says otherwise and of course
congress can say otherwise and at the
heart of this battle is a fairly arcane
law that deals with
simply who has jurisdiction to actually
prosecute crimes
here the mca applies to oklahoma on its
usual terms saying that
only the federal government and not the
state may prosecute native americans for
crimes committed in indian country of
course the larger question is whether
this decision in the words of ted cruz
gives away half of oklahoma but really
the practical implications of this
decision are not that dramatic the case
does not
change any land ownership in eastern
oklahoma oklahomans are not going to be
forced to abandon their homes and walk a
thousand miles in search of a new home
the decision also does not grant the
tribe criminal jurisdiction over
non-native americans but it does mean
that state prosecutors lack authority to
pursue criminal cases against
native american defendants in parts of
oklahoma that
includes most of tulsa the state's
second largest city but in fairness
there's a lot left
unresolved the majority decision left
open the possibility of other impacts
between territorial rights and taxation
and other jurisdictional issues
but the court felt that oklahoma and
the native american tribes could resolve
these things amicably
it's unlikely that anything dramatic is
going to happen after this decision
the state and five tribes issued a joint
statement stating that
the nations and the state are committed
to implementing a framework of shared
jurisdiction that will preserve
sovereign interest
and rights to self-government while
affirming jurisdictional understandings
procedures laws and regulations that
support public safety
our economy and private property rights
we will continue our work
confident that we can accomplish more
together than any of us could
alone so even if you live in eastern
oklahoma
it's unlikely that your day-to-day life
is going to be affected very much
and if you live in western oklahoma and
you're trying to get a hold of a friend
in eastern oklahoma
you'll want a cell phone service that
works in both regardless of whether
eastern oklahoma remains a part of the
state and ting mobile is
just the cell service to reach the state
formerly known as oklahoma
ting provides great lte coverage because
it uses the t-mobile sprint
and verizon networks so you get the
benefit of three massive networks
wherever you go no matter which part of
the state you live in
ting mobile is a different kind of
mobile provider with ting you only pay
for the actual data and services you use
at the end of the month
and because you're paying for only what
you actually use ting customers pay on
average just 23 dollars per month for
one device
and with ting you can use almost any
cell phone including the newest iphones
and pixel phones
and you can use the same phone number
you're using right now there's no
contract overage fees or any other
carrier tricks you just pay a fair price
for the talk text and data that you use
every month and ting has award-winning
customer service
because they don't have any brick and
mortar stores they pour all of their
resources into their phone and online
support if you have any issues you can
just
give them a call and you'll immediately
talk to a real human being ting is an
especially good deal if you're around
wi-fi all the time which
of course most of us are because we're
working from home because
you aren't actually using any data on
the cell service you're just using your
wi-fi so you'll end up paying way less
than you do right now
and ting gives you the option to pay
only for what you use and if you go to
legaleagle.ting.com you can use your
last bill to compare just how much you
would save
and legal eagles will get a 25 credit by
going to legaleagle.ting.com and that
could cover your entire first month of
service
so just click on the link in the
description and since there are no
contracts you can try it for a month
no strings attached again all you have
to do is click the link in the
description or go to legaleagle.ting.com
and get a 25 credit for whatever service
you want
plus clicking on that link really helps
out this channel so do you agree with my
analysis
are you mad that you watched 20 minutes
of clickbait about a dry supreme court
case that probably won't have much real
world effect
leave your objections in the comment and
check out this playlist with all of my
other real law reviews talking about all
the crazy stuff that's happening with
the protests
covet 19 and basically all of the news
there's a lot of it
so click on this playlist and i'll see
you in court